at New Horizons Center for Learning
students are rocking out to the beat of
Their Own Drum
[Music]
it's the only private school in the
Valley catering to students with
learning disabilities through ART life
skills and foreign culture and in Mr
York's music class music is their
universal language everyone has the
ability to learn anything
and that's what we're here to do is to
help them learn and it's not just about
the music it does teach the kids a lot
of other skills they learn how to think
ahead how to set up stages how to solve
issues not focus on problems but look at
Solutions just ask the members of the
flying walrus
the band has been rehearsing every week
since August to put together a big
upcoming concert 7th grader Gabe brosher
says while practice runs are a ton of
fun it's also a lot of hard work and
patience like I love the songs we do and
then the people are so supportive
everyone Mr York our teacher and all
those kids in the band are super nice
and supportive of me learning and not
always getting stuff Perfect Since
joining the band 8th grader Mars beach
has gained confidence and some new
friends and I felt like I found a new
family and I've always felt comforted in
this Auditorium whenever I'm with them
and it's always something I look forward
to principal Kirsten Lopez says music is
just another Outlet to give students a
voice as teachers provide a
multi-sensory curriculum to support
students development and growth so that
depending on your special learning style
we're not only teaching to your strength
but we're supplementing with the part
that you struggle with
they just might see the world a little
bit differently and really we try to
instill in them that we need that if we
were all the same what a boring place it
would be
the flying walruses fun name right are
going to play next Tuesday afternoon at
New Horizon School the concert is open
to any families that may want to check
out the school for their own child